it's great to be joined today by Glenn
while who's the principal researcher at
Microsoft Research New England and along
with Eric Posner the co-author of the
new book radical markets uprooting
capitalism and democracy for a just
society and maybe we'll start Glenn with
the four adjust society I mean what as
your as you approach the writing of this
book what were the unjust elements of
society that we're kind of like the
framework for for what you wrote well I
think that there are several things that
are going wrong in our society one is
the fact that we have this enormous and
growing inequality so much of the wealth
going to so few people who don't really
make contributions that merit such
disproportional share of the social
wealth another huge problem is the way
that our economy is stagnating and
people have fewer choices less freedom
less opportunities today many people
feel then that then their parents had
and finally maybe most importantly our
society seems to be rife with areas
where minorities are being oppressed by
majorities and we don't have a really
good way to resolve that problem you
know we sometimes have judges try to
protect one group but that ends up
leading to all sorts of political
dissatisfaction and conflict so on all
these levels or society really seems to
be not responding to the demands of
citizens and that's what we're trying to
address here one of the areas maybe we
can we can choose to dive in here is
your second chapter in the book called
radical democracy where you talk about a
system of quadratic voting which I find
super interesting what is a sort of
layman's term a explanation of what
quadratic voting is well the basic
problem as I mentioned that we're trying
to address is that minorities are
usually protected in our current system
by the will of judges but you know
judges aren't really democratically
elected and aren't really accountable to
the public on the other hand majority
rule wouldn't really work because you
think about an issue like gay marriage
that wouldn't be fair to you have
everyone have exactly one vote on that
issue so the question is how do we
resolve this Quadra
voting is a solution where every citizen
would have an equal number of votes but
they wouldn't have to spend all of those
votes all on you know just one vote per
issue or per election if an issue is
more important to someone if someone
knew more about an issue they could
choose to spend more of their vote
credits on that issue and people could
get a lot of votes on the issues most
important less votes on the issues less
important to them and there's this
little twist which is that because you
don't want everyone to spend all their
votes on the one issue the caramels most
that they care most about you actually
get more votes the more evenly you
spread your votes so the cost of votes
in units of these credits is the square
of the number of votes that you get so
in other words if you choose to support
four different initiatives rather than
one you would not end up having four
times the number of votes but I guess
what would it be sixteen or I guess I'm
not exactly sure I'm visualizing the
math yeah it depends it depends exactly
on here's here's an example um if you
have a hundred credits and there are ten
issues we actually ran a survey like
this if you put all your credits on one
issue you'd get 10 votes on that issue
because 10 is the square root of 100 but
if you put equal numbers of votes on all
the issues you'd get roughly 3 or 4
votes on every issue so that's like 30
votes so you see by spreading things out
more equal you get almost three times as
much total influence but in a more
diffuse way across issues so you know
I'm preparing for the interview I read
critiques of some of your ideas and the
one that seemed to come up often with
the quadratic voting is the idea that
this fundamentally violates one-person
one-vote and that idea but I know that
that that's an issue that that you
address so how do you address that issue
well so the question is what do we value
about one person one vote
is it the rigidity that every person has
to have exactly one vote on every issue
or is it the fact that we all should be
equals politically I actually think that
if it's the latter which is what I think
we should care about then quadratic
voting is actually more true to that
principle because you think about
minorities if if you're
they say an african-american living in
the inner city in the United States you
don't have equality just because you
have the same one-person one-vote on
every issue you might get gerrymandered
and even beyond that you just you know
you're a minority and so you're gonna
lose on a whole variety of issues where
majorities can rule it's much more
consistent with the principle of
equality that each of us gets an equal
total amount of voice but that we can
choose to concentrate that voice on
issues that are most important to us so
that we have greater freedom to push for
the things that really matter and really
affect our interests I'm curious whether
quadratic voting and some of the other
ideas in the book which which we can we
can get into as well in your in your
mind is sort of the underlying
philosophy a sort of utilitarianism
where you're sort of measuring outcomes
and whether we call it marginal utility
to society or the economy I don't really
know but in reading it my thought was
that there's a very utilitarian
underpinning although it's sort of like
a social utilitarianism of some kind or
am I just way off yeah well I think a
lot of people have that perception and
certainly utilitarianism and that sort
of thinking was one way that we helped
that helped us come up with these ideas
but I wouldn't say that I'm a
utilitarian or that the book relies on
you being a utilitarian because we
approach things from many different
perspectives I mean some people are
utilitarian some people care about
inequality for its own sake some people
care about I'm not having oppressive
authorities that dominate people but not
so much about utility exactly our book
helps advance all of those goals and we
try to argue for it from all those
different perspectives there's something
in religion that's called syncretism
which is that many different people
might all worship the same God but they
view different aspects of it and this
book is written very much in that spirit
we don't want to take too strong of a
stand on whether it's utilitarianism or
autonomy or Liberty or things like this
because we believe that these ideas can
help improve along all
those dimensions and we aren't gonna
resolve you know philosophical or
religious disputes in a book like this
what we're instead gonna do is propose
new ways of organizing our society to
advance values that many of us share
some of the ideas seem at first glance
more difficult pragmatically to even
think about how they might be
implemented in your first chapter you
talk about common common ownership self
assess tax which we could talk about in
more detail potentially you also talk
about ways of uniting the world workers
with a visa system where individuals
would be able to sponsor visas for
people from other countries which of
these I'm curious do you think would be
the most and I know this is not your
focus but which would be the most
pragmatically viable if you had to
choose one where we could most
approximate change the soonest is there
one oh yeah I think that what I would
say is it depends a lot on whether you
mean implement the full extent of the
proposal or where can we make the most
near-term progress in I'd say in terms
of better society
yeah so the data is labor chapter in
which we argue that people should be
able to receive compensation for the
contributions that they make to the
machine learning and artificial
intelligence systems of companies like
Google and Facebook rather than just
having that data be taken from them is
probably the most palatable and widely
appreciated of the ideas and probably
the one that will get off the ground you
know at a broad scale the quickest so
the idea would be all of the data all of
your activity that's taking place on
platforms which couldn't be the Google
universe the Facebook universe what
could be any of these that you would
somehow as a contributor of your data to
that ecosystem be compensated along what
lines are we talking about literally
financial compensation yeah eventually
absolutely and you know we imagine
building what we call a data labor
movement once people wake up get quote
cyber woke to the value that their data
is creating and this
digital economy and the way that the AI
systems that are supposed to replace our
jobs are actually based on all of our
contributions people will start
demanding payment through sort of labor
unions of a new modern digital sort and
fair terms of both use and compensation
can be negotiated that way yeah that's
interesting because there's often the
idea that listen Facebook Ads don't work
on me in the sense that I haven't ever
bought anything which looked let's
assume that that's true although it can
sometimes be hard to figure out exactly
why you did buy something at some point
in your life so I'm of no value so I
just don't really care about this but
the truth is that the algorithm with
which successful targets of a product or
surface but we're targeted was data that
did come from you and thus it does have
some economic value even if you're not
actually buying stuff yeah and it's not
just the targeting of ads I mean that's
what we're all familiar with today but
going forward the greatest value these
companies are going to create is not
from advertising really instead it's
from the artificial intelligent systems
that they're training on our data and
that they'll sell the companies to
automate
for example I don't know if you saw
Google's recent new assistant yet the
process of you know making reservations
for someone so they're gonna automate
that and their training all that based
on our data so people are going to be
losing their jobs and no one's going to
be getting a new job even though all
that that system relies on input that we
put in the book is fascinating it's
called radical markets uprooting
capitalism and democracy for a just
society Glenn thanks so much for talking
to me about this today thanks a lot
David